yo quiero preguntarles inicialmente si
alguna vez escucharon o perdón si
escucharon hablar de esa palabra ante la
mano quien no escuchó hablar de
sostenibilidad
para que se retire por favor
entonces si podemos tener esa
conversación
quiero contarles cuatro historias de la
sostenibilidad una tarea que se me
encomendó a mí hace unos diez años
aproximadamente cuando fui contratado en
la universidad pontificia liberiana para
ser docente arquitecto de sostenibilidad
y enfrentar un tema que nos ha llevado a
tener una perspectiva de nuestra
posición frente al planeta
comienza por hacer unos análisis son los
estudios previos que nos muestran que si
uno se pone a mirar muy de cerca el
concepto de sostenibilidad vamos a
encontrar un sinónimo bastante aterrador
apocalípsis porque parece que eso fuera
lo que nos estuvieran vendiendo con una
idea de sostenibilidad que el planeta se
está acabando que los recursos naturales
que la calidad del aire que las especies
que la extinción que la degradación de
los ecosistemas y si a eso le sumamos
también inequidad hambre pobreza
desolación entonces siempre que uno mira
sostenibilidad se involucra una noción
un poco de temor poco de miedo
y yo que soy profesor que me encantan
las clases de los profesores como lo
acabamos de ver fantásticas muy
motivadoras muy lindos mensajes
tengo que asumir una posición casi que
una responsabilidad y me hago la
pregunta como un enseño mis estudiantes
que es sostenibilidad sin tener que
pasar por ese momento difícil doloroso
triste de poner en perspectiva nuestro
desarrollo social y su relación con el
planeta entonces me puse a investigar un
poco
como podría construir una noción de
sostenibilidad y encuentro hoy diez años
después de ese ejercicio académico estas
cuatro definiciones de sostenibilidad
la primera la encontré en este libro
maravilloso de produjo en una
conferencia muy linda y una
recomendación para todos donde nos da
una noción de esperanza y yo me convenzo
profundamente que la sostenibilidad
tiene que estar marcada dentro de un
concepto de esperanza y esa esperanza
está arraigada en que algo que nació en
investigación por todo el planeta donde
establece determina que asistimos al
desarrollo o al movimiento social más
importante que ha tenido la historia de
la humanidad un movimiento social por la
sostenibilidad un movimiento que está
constituido según los datos de polvo que
ni su investigación entre una media
entre 130.000 y 500.000 organizaciones
en todo el planeta organizaciones
civiles organizaciones sociales
organización de grupos de amigos que
están trabajando por
todo aquello que es justicia social
equidad todo aquello que es bello
importante para el ser humano
y por lo tanto tenemos una noción de
esperanza y yo quisiera que cada uno de
ustedes se pensará en este momento ahí
donde está sentado qué está haciendo
usted por la sostenibilidad del planeta
y en el momento en el que usted es más
consciente de reciclar ahorrar a
aguardar energía utilizar menos su
vehículo compartir o en el momento de
que usted con sus amigos tiene una
asociación que va a visitar barrios
populares de pronto oa visitar comunas y
llevar ayuda un poco de esperanza con
sus familias usted hace parte de ese
movimiento social y usted no lo sabe y
parte del secreto que tiene esta noción
de experiencia es que no lo sepamos
porque está afuera según nos dice por
hawking está fuera de los radares de los
medios de comunicación y los discursos y
las agendas políticas
y cuando uno logra entender eso se da
cuenta entonces que efectivamente la
sostenibilidad es esperanza y que si
damos apoyo a un movimiento como este
entonces sí podemos seguir adelante con
nuestra especie y encontrar nuestras
motivaciones y nuestras razones
a partir de esa condición comencé a
diseñar o a estructurar
mis cursos de sostenibilidad para los
futuros arquitectos que espero se hagan
se vayan haciendo cargo de su
responsabilidad frente a ese escenario
pero después como activa como
profesional activo como académico como
consultor y como arquitecto diseñador me
construye una noción de sostenibilidad
real porque la esperanza digamos es algo
que nos puede surgir desde el corazón
desde las motivaciones personales a
nuestros propios valores pero cuando
analizamos hoy en que está la
sostenibilidad tengo de primero el
movimiento social que ya les conté que
existe del cual usted hace parte pero
hay también una postura del estado una
postura política en la cual desde el
ambiente construido que es el área
conocimiento donde yo me manejo tenemos
una fuerte normativa y unos incentivos
asistimos a un cambio en las leyes para
el desarrollo sostenible que promueven
de las leyes policivas a las leyes por
incentivos y por beneficios cuando nos
vemos en este escenario pasamos a ver
también como una industria como la que
nos manejamos nosotros los arquitectos
un industria la construcción que tiene
altos impactos ambientales tiene digamos
unos costos sociales importantes empieza
a transformarse en un escenario donde
también entendemos que la sostenibilidad
muy buen negocio tan buen negocio que un
banco muy famoso que no voy a decir le
puso el alma y está financiando
proyectos de construcción sostenible en
anterior
el grupo al también
y finalmente cuál es la postura de los
arquitectos los profesionales los
ingenieros y todos quienes estamos
trabajando por esa condición de
sostenibilidad y encontramos hoy una
noción de sostenibilidad real estas 4
tensiones nos dan hoy más esa esperanza
esa condición de tener una
sostenibilidad real si muy bien ahora
tengo que regresar a las aulas de clase
y cuando voy al aula de clase
aquí están los de los factores que les
decía las motivaciones de la revista
semana para dar un poco más de
fundamentación en que nos movemos aquí
usted se puede ir inscribiendo de cuál
de estos factores social ambiental y
económicos que hace parte de ese
movimiento
pero como vivimos en las clases para
allá de nuestros profesores
nos veamos húmedo abocado a esto la
realidad no se puede enseñar
la realidad solo se puede vivir y eso me
lleva a mí al tercer factor tengo
esperanza tengo realidad y ahora tengo
acción entonces diseño mi curso de
arquitectura sostenible en el cual parto
de la premisa o el reto de llevar a mis
estudiantes a vivir una realidad y esa
realidad que quizás muchos la pasamos
por encima aunque la veamos todos los
días está presente en nuestras ciudades
no sé si ustedes sabían que una de cada
cuatro personas que vive en medellín
vive en uno de estos barrios
vive en estas condiciones vive en estas
situaciones donde hay unas temas de
carencias seguridades hay unas
vulnerabilidades hay unos entornos
difíciles que tenemos que enfrentar y yo
que seguramente muchos pasamos por acá
cuando vamos de fin de semana a las
fincas en san jerónimo en santafé de
antioquia y pasamos a una velocidad de
60 porque hay una cámara más adelante
entonces quiera 60 cierto de eso estamos
pendientes de la cámara pero estamos
quizás obviando que aquí están viviendo
personas con las claves con las que
quizás incluso interactuamos todos los
días con el portero de una institución
con la persona que nos sirve el almuerzo
en la cafetería estamos interactuando
con ellos pero no estamos conociendo
cuál es su contexto en donde se están
moviendo sí sí son hinchas del nacional
o no
admiro los círculos rojo y verde del
rojo y azul yo solamente pensó en el
medellín ya no me está gustando la
presentación previa
hasta africanas diferentes tamaños y se
me terminó el juego
esta realidad es la realidad a la cual
yo invito a mis estudiantes de
arquitectura los reto porque yo no les
puedo decir que existen pobres que ahí
están por supuesto que existen pero que
han hablado con ellos quien los conoce
quién sabe su nombre y además cuestionó
la formación en arquitectura porque
todos arquitectos nos formamos creando
lugares fantásticos bellos hermosos para
gente que no conocemos para estadísticas
para una familia de cuatro personas
quién les dijo ustedes que la familia
grande cuatro personas porque son de
cuatro personas en las familias hay
niños hay ancianos hay personas con
discapacidad con necesidades especiales
tenemos que saber eso y entonces la
primera premisa que yo le hago a mis
estudiantes asumiendo algunos riesgos y
algunos retos es vaya y conozca esto
miren como se extiende en nuestra ciudad
miren cómo se va conectando y ahora si
le juntamos a esto la calidad del aire
que es esa realidad también que estamos
viviendo entonces vamos juntando estos
discursos de aproximarnos
la sostenibilidad como realidad
y el reto que tienen que hacer mis
estudiantes es vaya y conozca una
familia de estas vaya y sepa su nombre
bien se diga pregúntele de dónde vino
pregúntele cómo son sus consumos
energéticos pregúntele su estado de
salud pregúntele si además cómo está
constituida su familia
pregunte de cuáles son sus sueños cuáles
son sus expectativas y diseñe para ellos
una reforma o una rehabilitación que le
permita a esa familia quizás algún día
acceder a un beneficio oa un retorno que
se pueda dar ya sea a través de un
subsidio o algo y en estas tareas
llevamos cinco años y en este ejercicio
hemos hecho ya más de 400 proyectos
800 estudiantes de arquitectura en esos
últimos 5 años 400 proyectos donde el
estudiante además entiende que esa
realidad tiene unos valores asociados a
la realidad que se ajusta a correr un
muro 10 centímetros al valor que tiene
una puerta a poner un closet en una casa
o el valor que tiene un acabado o una
buena cocina y porque eso tiene otros
impactos y además les digo con un
presupuesto teórico proponga un proyecto
de arquitectura que le mejore la calidad
de vida a estas personas y ahí están mis
estudiantes desarrollando sus estudios y
no hay una premisa del trabajo que
hacemos en la clase de que el estudiante
le mejore la vida esa persona porque eso
es digamos una falsa promesa no tenemos
los recursos para solucionar la vida de
estas personas o por lo menos no de ser
parte del objeto de nuestro curso
y en ese escenario hemos encontrado que
aproximadamente 400 familias que han
recibido este ejercicio que han abierto
sus puertas que han contado sus
expectativas que han compartido con sus
estudiantes que les han brindado en sus
niveles muy básicos de ingresos un
almuerzo un jugo de tomate de árbol que
se debe tomar porque hace parte de ese
compartir
y que quizás se puede entender un poco
que estas familias están recibiendo
ayuda de mis estudiantes pero la
realidad no es esa
son estas familias quienes están
ayudando a mis estudiantes a ser mejores
arquitectos
a entender en la arquitectura tiene
responsabilidades sociales
responsabilidades civiles más allá de
ganarse un press care de ganar su plena
arquitectura construir una biblioteca
que no se puede usar
no voy a decir cuál
hacer arquitectos mucho más conscientes
y sensibles por esa transformación
necesaria del ambiente construido
esa es nuestra premisa y con esto hemos
desarrollado incluso proyectos de
investigación que van mucho más allá
como esta tesis de grado de arquitectura
que fue premiada en brasil con medalla
de oro investigación donde esta
estudiante cogió los casos de estudio y
analizó cuáles son las patologías las
enfermedades que se desarrollan en las
personas por habitar en viviendas con
malas cocinas malos baños y malas
condiciones de habitabilidad y entonces
empiezan a aparecer una serie de
enfermedades como la diabetes la
depresión problemas cardíacos problemas
intestinales problemas respiratorios y
todo eso está asociado a un ambiente
construido de baja calidad y hemos
identificado además que si el estado
hiciera inversiones más en mejorar el
hábitat entonces esto podría salir de un
sistema de salud muy descompensado y
podríamos tener quizás una acción de
acción de salud preventiva mejorando las
viviendas de esas personas
independientes del peo te de la
reglamentación o de una ventana una
medianería porque esa gente de todas
maneras necesitan respirar necesitan una
mejor temperatura
y tenemos también una tesis de maestría
que estamos por terminar donde le
estamos generando a la gente una serie
de manuales para decirle mejore su casa
revoque un muro cambio cambio de a
cambio un chape cuando tenga algún
dinero que les sobre pongo un piso con
una puerta en un baño abre una ventana y
ventiló algo una mejora de su hábitat
para llegar a una mejor condición social
y esperamos que este proyecto que se ha
convertido uno de los centros académicos
de mi desarrollo como profesor se
convierta en algún momento una política
de salud o una política de
rehabilitación de viviendas y ya estamos
listos para entregarle al estado a
lisbeth que nos está patrocinando en
este momento esta información y llamar
la atención pero yo me quedo tranquilo
con que de esos 800 estudiantes digan un
porcentaje el 5% el 10% sean personas
diferentes frente a su visión de la
arquitectura la sostenibilidad y la
realidad
y yo me quedo tranquilo con eso me quedo
tranquilo que cuando vuelvan a diseñar
piensen que existen personas que tienen
necesidades y que la arquitectura es
mucho más que hacer un render o que
vender una imagen bonita
y ya para terminar les digo muy
personalmente que yo creo en las utopías
porque yo de pequeño leia julio verne y
ahora también les puedo decir que la
sostenibilidad es un sueño y la podemos
soñar y la podemos soñar en que en el
ejercicio profesional que estamos
haciendo ahorita esta es la medellín que
recibimos en el año 2017 y nos hacemos
la pregunta será que podemos cambiar una
ciudad será que la podemos transformar
porque no soñamos una mejor ciudad y
este es el medellín que esperamos
encontrar o terminar en 2020 y ese es el
medellín que estamos haciendo hoy ahora
si queremos tener la expectativa de
sembrar árboles para limpiar la calidad
del aire cuando se me pregunto por la
siembra de árboles para limpiar el aire
308 árboles que sembramos en la avenida
oriental alcanzan a generar oxígeno para
tres personas un año y por ahí pasan un
millón doscientas mil personas al día
la respuesta es no sembramos árboles por
supuesto que hay que sembrar los pero
parte del sueño es sembrar el árbol y
verlo crecer y esta es la ciudad que
tendríamos que esperar la ciudad que
quisiéramos transformar desde nuestro
ejercicio obviamente esto hace parte de
los sueños o hace parte de las utopías
pero me tengo confianza que tengo
confianza porque hemos conquistado
algunas pequeñas victorias como está la
avenida oriental que recibimos y nos
dimos una 10 ciudad para una pela pero
una cara fea nos dimos la batalla
política
la batalla técnica para cambiar esto por
esto
claro ahí aparece el render claro ahí
aparece la imagen pero hoy queremos
cambiar esto por esto y este jardín
seguramente ustedes ya se dieron cuenta
que ese jardín hoy ya existe en la
oriental no están más esas estructuras
de concreto y cristal que incrementan el
calor que incrementaba la temperatura
que incrementan el ruido y usted si pasa
hoy por acá va a encontrar mariposas
cuca rones bichos una que otra tórtola
un poco de basura algunos indigentes que
duermen ahí cómodamente pero ese jardín
lo tenemos que cuidar todos esa es la
apuesta que queremos hacer y también
quisiera decirles esa es la ciudad que
nosotros desde estas transformaciones
queremos merecemos y que podemos lograr
y esa es la sostenibilidad como cambio
para decirlo pues porque justifica que
me han invitado
decirles sí creo las utopías si quiero
participar de eso y si quiero invitarlos
a ustedes a que se motiven a ser parte
de estas transformaciones y finalmente
quiero decir algo muy personal
como logramos
que esto se vuelva una realidad
yo creo en esto
mucha gente pequeña en lugares pequeños
haciendo cosas pequeñas puede cambiar el
mundo y la sostenibilidad es una
oportunidad para eso
pero aquí se va a quebrar la voz
cada uno tiene que tener una propia
motivación y mi motivación es sin duda
está
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]